a ratio is on Twitter Dave is a car a
bad investment even if you have the
lease under a company well I
if you take $30,000 and you turn it into
$10,000 a $30,000 car loses value down
to $10,000 you can't hide that inside of
a company you still lost if you own the
company or if you didn't put it in the
company you own the car you still turn
thirty thousand dollars into ten
thousand dollars putting it in a company
doesn't make the thirty thousand dollars
not turn into ten thousand dollars it
still turns into $10,000 and a lease is
just another way of financing a vehicle
you don't dodge the loss in value with
the lease you pay for it in the lease
think about it if you leased a $30,000
car and you drive off the lot with it
and you pay payments for three years and
you turn the car back in the car is
worth ten thousand dollars
do you think the car company that you
leased that from is gonna lose that
twenty thousand dollars from that thirty
down to ten oh no they're not gonna lose
that money they charged you for that
twenty thousand inside your lease
payment dummy
so I mean your lease payment includes
the loss of value you're renting the car
while you're renting it it's going down
in value and so the included in your
rent is the loss in value the cost of
capital called interest and their profit
it's all built into the lease so you're
giving them profit you're giving them
interest and you're covering the loss in
value while you rent the car for the
three years and that includes the twenty
thousand dollars in loss and so the
lease does not hide you should leased
depreciating assets that's the dumbest
but statement I've ever heard in my life
and these quote financial people say
that you should lease depreciating
assets no you shouldn't it's just fine
depreciating assets is all you're doing
you're covering the loss of value in
that because the lease companies are
fairly good with math they don't sign up
to lose money on the stuff they're
leasing to you they're renting you a
copier they're renting you a car they're
renting you a cellphone whatever it is
and when you give it back to them it's
worth a lot less than when you took it
out of their store and you cover the
cost of the loss in value plus profit
plus interest thus comes your payment so
leasing a car is actually when you back
into the math the typical car lease is
somewhere around the effective rate of
about 14% interest
not counting profit and how can you do
that well you can use a financial
calculator okay it's fairly easy if you
have the opening part of the lease on a
closed-end car lease is a fairly simple
equation you've got the equate you've
got all the numbers for the variables
for your math equation for those of you
that know how to run a financial
calculator you got the what the car is
what the the MSRP is of the car at the
time you take it off the lot what's the
sticker on the car what's the car its
residual value meaning what can you buy
it for at the end of the lease the
difference in those two is how big a
loss they're taking on it actually it's
not even the MSRP it'd be more like
their invoice minus their holdbacks
what's their real cost on the car okay
what's up what's the dealer's real cost
on the car the manufacturer is real cost
on the car somewhere around invoice
minus residual value that's how much
it's gonna lose in value during the time
you've got the lease out they're not
gonna let you buy it at the end of the
lease other than what they think it's
gonna be worth at that time you take
that figure that loss in value and
deduct that from the lease payments and
take out a profit margin I just make up
a profit margin number about 10 percent
or something they want to make on the
sale of the vehicle and the rest of that
is called
cost of capital translation that's
interest
and your cost of capital when you put
that into a financial calculator during
that period of time we'll back out most
of the time right around thirteen to
fourteen percent interest consequently
Smart Money Magazine Consumer Reports
and Dave Ramsey's calculator I'll say
leasing a car is the most expensive way
the most expensive way the biggest
ripoff in all of automotive methods of
all the automotive methods all the ways
you could get at it so you can pay cash
for a car you can finance a car straight
up or you can lease a car what's the
most expensive way to drive a car of
those three the car lease they make more
money on leasing than they do on the
sale of the automobile that's how this
works
folks they make more money on financing
than they do on the sale of the
automobile but they would rather release
it to you than anything because they
make more money on that the dealer when
they sell the contract for the lease
payments back to their manufacturer the
Lexus dealer selling it back to Lexus
Motor Credit the Toyota dealer back to
Toyota Motor Credit the Ford dealer back
to Ford Motor Credit they make more on
the sale of the merchandise I mean on
the sale of the contract for the
payments than they do on the sale of the
car so the car lease is nicknamed around
here the car fleece because there's an
old saying that if you got ripped off
you have been fleeced like fleecing a
sheep cutting all his hair off leaving
him bald you took his hair you got
fleeced you got screwed that's what a
car fleece is the most expensive worst
way to own a vehicle cars go and you
can't hide that inside of a company a
bad deal is a bad deal inside of a
company a bad deal is a bad deal the
math sucks on this stuff now I'm not
against you having a nice car I'm just
against a nice car having you the
average car payment
America right now is 506 dollars over 84
months that's according to the National
Auto Dealers Association so if you take
506 dollars and invest it from age 30
days 70 in a decent growth stock mutual
fund you have 5.6 million dollars I hope
you like the car
so those car payments are costing you
car payments are the mantra of the
middle-class you guarantee you will be
broke your whole life as long as you
stay in car payments because it's the
most expensive thing that most people
buy that goes down in value the most
expensive thing most people buys a home
at least it goes up in value but we go
finance these cars and you're sitting
there with a thirty five thousand dollar
kid hauler with payments coming out your
ears that's six hundred and forty-two
dollars a month so that everybody's safe
and has their own DVD player in the back
of the headrest but they have no college
fund well that's just stupid you're
driving their college fund but what a
world we live in where a minivan is now
a status symbol god help us seriously
can you believe what some of these
minivans cost have you looked at a Honda
Odyssey I mean you can get a really nice
Mercedes for what you can get Honda
Odyssey for lievable yeah I mean think
people think think pay cash for your
vehicles if you want to be wealthy buy
vehicles the total up to be less than
half your annual income if you want to
be wealthy I don't want you to have a
junk car I'm gonna ask you to drive a
thousand dollar beater the rest of your
life unless you make $3,000 a year if
you make $3,000 a year we need to work
on your career
you need to keep your cars down and not
fleece them and not get worn out by
these car manufacturers they are getting
filthy rich on your stupidity you're
gonna stop and think really